what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation we're gonna watch she-hulk
episode five today john how are you i am
what does it matter it's koi's birthday
today happy birthday cool literally
right when this airs boy's birthday
midnight happy birthday coy thank you
for being here on your actual stroke of
midnight birthday i got to start with
you guys i'm like truly i i was said it
before we were on air i'm very happy to
kick it off with you guys so this is
special to me as a birthday present to
koi follow him on tick tick tick tock
tick tick tick tick tock 50 seconds 30
seconds one minute three minute videos
follow him today that would be the the
best gift you can give him and wish him
a happy birthday in the comments would
you shut up john it's koi's birthday
nice sorry about him i mean he's just he
gets he gets on it it happens
[Music]
leave a like for coy's birthday
subscribe and click the notification
bell for koi's birthday full-length
watch as long as we sync her with your
own copy of shioka for a patron super
sexy rejects
koi's birthday and uh thank you to
prepper for helping us coy's birthday
all right guys let's watch koi's
birthday i hope daredevil shows up for
him i just my birthday it's for your
birthday he's going to look at the
camera thanks matt foggy
birthday
[Music]
she's suing me over the name she-hulk
but that's my name
[Music]
birthday
[Music]
supports the channel
strength is beauty beauty is strength
what makes you beautiful she-hulk by
titan
be strong be beautiful own who you are
by titania nicely done amazing
that's actually a thing you can buy on
twitter i've seen this ad this woman
titania has trademarked my name well
that's dumb why would you let her do
that i didn't let her chet huh
the way trademark works is whoever gets
there first gets it you know so if you
would have done yours first
[Laughter]
thank you chad
very helpful chet
[Laughter]
oh i'm having influence or ptsd right
now what seems to be the issue you're
using my name to sell your trashy
product and you're suing me
could you take a photo of us oh my god
yes
back up let me just give me some space
[Laughter]
she-hulk is just a thing that happened
to me
that is a really good perspective to
have i do admit though there are parts
of it that i enjoy okay you're not done
no hangover being able to walk home at
night with headphones on without being
afraid everyone's been straight but
what's happening nick oh we're just
talking to myself
all right i can't pretend like i'm here
for a friendly visit
[Music]
[Laughter]
will you stand in line with me waiting
for a sneaker drop the iron man threes
are coming down they're limited oh damn
you need two pairs i wanted a rock and
one to stock
my man [ __ ] so much
i got a guy alonzo the drip broker you
can find anything you're looking for
fashion wise
can this
drip broker
find someone who could do custom
clothing for say
a super human sized person
oh she's gonna get an outfit yeah
no doubt
okay
i'm gonna need to call my favorite right
now but you haven't even done the
original favor
i need to watch whatever this dude does
i love the both of them
uh my boy alonso sent me alonzo okay
what's the order no no well
was that chinese i'm not chinese we've
said we're not cops
[Laughter]
get that drip
this kind of hustle okay what do you
need i got everything
oh my god
avengers t-shirt this is this says
avengers you don't like the vongers ah
purple
avengers i want custom-made clothing for
a superhero
question
and do you know who the guy is he won't
meet with you he's very exclusive okay
so do you know the guy
[Music]
you are the guy
okay fine i'll buy one of your bondage
t-shirts and a matching hat yes of
course i want to complete the ensemble
[Music]
[Laughter]
drip
comic con 2015.
actually my client is an avenger she's
one of the top tier ones sir 15-minute
consultation my assistant will set up
the appointment
is everything all right sir
[Music]
no
[Laughter]
so the name she-hulk was never really
mine officially everyone in the media
just started calling me that but now
this incredibly awful slightly
super-powered woman titanium yeah i'm
i'm gonna stop you because you know none
of that's my concern
ouch
no one hires a firm that can't handle
its own messes
i am going to fix this sir
no you won't mallory
why didn't you trademark your own
pseudonym i never even thought about it
you know why would i uh
did dr strange have to trademark his
name did thor you chose two examples of
people who use their real names
this is the person who legally
outmaneuvered you yeah
but if you're going to be my client you
need to dress like you respect yourself
and not like a football player pleading
no contest to a dui oh my god
well done
nice suit shred ouch jennifer walters
was not interested in the she-hulk name
until it became associated with this
incredibly successful line of products
my name never has been and never will be
she-hulk it's lazy it's reductive and
it's straight-up garbage this is really
bad
some random guy on the news came up with
it but it's stuck uh so now whether i
like it or not i am forever
she-hulk will recess until thursday
[Laughter]
it's gonna be your tinder
it's courtroom scenes are fascinating
responsible for customer stupidity
getting easter eggs get all the easter
eggs
dresses
my client list is very exclusive you
said she was one it hasn't been
announced yet because they're still
working at the deal and stuff but
basically she's an adventure the hulk is
her cousin
by blood
yeah she needs a suit that's going to
fit her both as jen
and as she-hulk something that would
require a lot of telling can we go ahead
and show them
did daredevil get his suit from this guy
that was the uh the guy in his show no
no no i think it's his gun
i mean come on have you ever done a hulk
before
this is huge
tinsley
order extra bolts of the stretch
wool
creepy disgusting
monstrous are you a client i am i'm one
of the biggest just had a meeting with
my favorite
lady lawyer no touching
yeah we should reconnect soon yeah
absolutely that'd be great yeah drinks
on me
you're behaving way different than the
date he went on a date with she-hulk
yeah
because i made a dating profile as
she-hulk and went on several dates as
she-hulk showing a clear pattern of
using the name subpoena
uh this
is how i win this case oh i'm parading
all the questionable men that you dated
in front of a courtroom
jen that's gonna be embarrassing yes
at the record show hank hill really
knows his pornography
my client used she-hulk but as a genuine
part of her identity
as you can see in the about me section
my client wrote and i quote mean green
and straight poured into these genes
[Laughter]
or in a partner my client wrote
a sturdy back and reinforced king-sized
bed
[Laughter]
we'd like to call our witnesses
my men
[Laughter]
she's like it's me the real she-hulk
impressed much she came across a little
tryhard to be honest her referring to
herself as she-hulk
in the third person and as a writer
myself i found that grating
that she was initially embarrassed by
the name she hulk
but then she embraced it you know that's
a beautiful part i guess i don't know
i'm the kind of guy a woman can really
open up to
[Laughter]
yep
would you have gone on the date if
she-hulk had instead presented as
jennifer walters nope
no
she's uh
not really my type but she-hulk she's uh
she-hulk's incredible she's amazing but
jennifer walters not amazing
the court finds in favor of
jennifer walters aka
she-hulk
motion for summary judgment is granted
titania and her subsidiaries will cease
usage of the she-hulk name effective
immediately didn't titania attack a
courtroom yep recently
this courtroom
oh
but that extremely attractive man said
in there
you can do better
you deserve better
oh
can i buy you a drink to uh say thanks
sure
so happy we're doing this
cheers
quite a strategy
slide is so tiny i don't know any other
lawyer who would humiliate themselves
that way to win a case oh yeah i mean
you can always count on me to throw
myself under the bus oh
everything that she-hulk brings to the
table and those guys were my best
options you can have literal superpowers
and some guy with an internet connection
will still think he can do better
oh my god i am so happy we're friends
now
uh-oh
i thought you were getting better
clothes
oh yeah my clothes
[Laughter]
hey luke
just here to get my suits
i meant daredevil's the latest suit oh
of course by the way
the yellow
i made you a little something
extra yes you did
oh wow
i i don't know that i'll really have an
occasion to say thank you jennifer thank
you hello this shouldn't be left out in
the open
oh do you see the top of the box
i told you he created a civic
sheer 30 seconds of energy that that
caused just pure clean
what's to come
i don't know what any of us said
[Laughter]
i did like that victoria alonso got a
little name drop there with the alonso
used over and over again one of the head
producers at marvel she's lovely that
was an easter egg yeah yeah yeah
there was uh an asgardian suit in the
background that was i don't know what
that black feathery thing was i was
trying to figure it out okay so
daredevil's gotta be the next episode
he's gotta be i swear to god if you're
not here next week i'm gonna be pissed
so the thing about that is uh
if i'm here on my birthday i'm gonna be
here all right
no post credits scene like daredevil's
enough
is there something wrong with the app
it's the first time no it's not
is there something wrong with the
miracle something happened oh man we can
actually do an ending explain daredevil
got his suit from him he's going to be i
need to explain and explain guys 30
seconds
tick-tock explained
right there
[Music]
the yellow daredevil suit he made it
and jen gets a new suit too i mean
that's nice daredevil
remember why we're all really here they
call
let's listen to koi talk for 30 minutes
all right so here's the reality of what
happened you're about to watch our whole
like 30 minute review
and now it's uh two in the morning after
saying goodbye to koi i got a call from
the cosmic wonder
and he was like yo did you catch all
those easter eggs during the credits and
i was like what
and he's like go to 25 something or
another he's like coy hadn't seen any of
this i called coin i was like coy you
got to come back
here i am
back in the seat so this is an insert
we're doing right now and then we'll
just go to the actual review that we had
because um yeah we were talking over
this all right
koi all right we got hulk shoes we got
oh the thing shoes deadpool deadpool
shoes deadpool shoes thing shoes uh
looks like the eye of agamotto up there
we got thanos shoes we got oh jesus
captain america obviously there's
deadpool's right there uh spider-man oh
my god black panther right next to it or
cyclops do you see cyclops yeah look
there that is cyclops he's right there
yeah prowler maybe on the bottom oh no
kang kang can get king
moon knight next to king
okay does any more color get filled in
uh electro and electro sony electro is
right there
doc that green and yellow one uh we're
at up
here
that's electronics oh that's like that's
the that's the sony excitement i just
had
uh we got it looks like this
is that jack-o'-lantern the purple is
that a jack like a orange skull like a
like a like a pumpkin
i think that's jacob
blow this up okay do you oh
see that one above captain marvel on the
on the the the the part of your shoe
that you squeeze when you have jordans
on is that a jack-o-lantern sure looks
like it i think those are
jack-o'-lantern shoes
what's this uh that looks alpha flight
is that alpha flight looks like an e
for elektra no i think that electric is
coming in hold on let me show you the
alpha flight logo like his situation
there
north star
i don't know about that
maybe i got excited
what is that
okay what's and then uh nova underneath
it if ever there was a time for you to
do your lean it is now
as far as you want boy definitely nova
underneath
um
i think neymar above elektra right there
it looks like there's a little um the
wing on his ankle yeah and that's that
looks like flesh plus green
um
doom
one of those looks like doom that one
you just went over it looks doomish to
me yeah yeah
uh hawkeye above it huh yeah good catch
um i definitely think papa thanos above
the thing right there
what i'm gonna do [ __ ] cable dude
a diagonal from deadpool silver surfer
next to her head
thor og thor next to her shoulder
we're gonna have to screenshot this and
put a text over what all them are
i'm just yelling [ __ ] just yelling and
i'm saying
it's gonna be happening
what shoes are you talking about right
now i'm wondering what the top left next
to the doctor strange ones are so do you
see the doctor strange symbol next to
that on the left oh is that the original
maybe hank pym ant-man like og let's go
with that okay that's a thing
it's cool they have cyclops shoes they
should make those shoes i would wear
their shoes
people would buy what does this mean if
these shoes exist
i mean i mean the thing and deadpool and
cyclops are already well-known heroes in
the marvel cinematic universe
what is this some sort of suicide squad
that's a great question i mean my mans
is shopping for shoes uh i feel like
that's hank pym like og 60s uh 1960s
costume
but i could be wrong
let's hope for all of our sakes you're
not yeah four editors
uh
where's the original brown suit
this is all the movie stuff god damn the
popularity of these movies
and your plan is working against you
when i google it doesn't go well
anyway i think that's hank pym so hank
pym doctor strange mysterious not alpha
flight uh what's what do we think that
purple and green is the one in the
no purple and green is that yeah and the
on the not the hulk
yeah well there's a bunch of purple and
greens so i assume that's our hulk
because down there is our kang and
there's jack-o-lantern it looks like the
hulk because it's got green purple
shorts and a grenade
yeah and then
nova i believe i don't know who that
plain yellow one is because it seems
fairly vague and the namor electro
uh all right so that's that area and
then hawkeye
uh dr doom it looks like not
necessary yeah that's that's that's
captain marvel there so who's the
captain marvel colors third down
under doom oh golly
can you tell no okay so we'll skip that
for now jack o'lantern captain marvel
[ __ ] spider-man moon knight kang
black panthers cyclops those aren't mr
miracle oh vision
captain america deadpool silver surfer
thor
nice
that's good so there's like five i don't
know the mysterious one looks like it
has some kind of bird design on it but
that's the best i can make out of this
orangey brown
okay some sort of bird some sort of
suicide squad
this is
amazing i love you just talking guys you
missed you missed one iron man the iron
man
iron man three
some might say the best iron man film
that i'm gonna need that heat all right
koi you've done your duty okay good i
came back
[Laughter]
oh wait okay that is definitely
jack-o'-lantern dude jack-o'-lantern one
of the most obscure wannabe hobgoblin
rip-offs from spider-man in the early
2000's and late nights such as hobgoblin
no oh it might be
probably a green goblin yeah that's a
yeah that's funny
but like it looks like jackal it does
probably green goblin okay so
has those things that look like little
tacos
so we'd confirm namorn electro and
captain marvel
uh confirmed hulk okay now i definitely
wonder what that symbol is the e
i've
that is ghost rider donnie blaze lives
underneath the doctor strange is ghost
rider
so we don't know the gold ones because
they're very vague but i think we got
like all but three those are zeus's
shoes just zoo shoes i'm not gonna write
a text out no it's not going to happen
you guys are trying to guess whatever
coins just bleeping me and like i'm
pointing and swearing and you're like
nah i don't even know i'm not gonna
thanks to our friends
for figuring this one out they're not
going to figure it out they're going to
be pointing all the wrong shoes in the
store
we'll just put these up
follow along i did at the order a second
ago and then i just but the ghost
writers knew that's dope yeah oh thing
shoes yeah we said that
this is so cool
it's peak if the first appearance of
deadpool in the mcu is these shoes
yeah man
maybe we'll get more shoes and we'll get
a comic book crossover maybe we'll get
like a batman shoe for a second i
thought that was a robin shoe underneath
things and nope that's definitely a
vision there what is this some sort of
comic book crossover kind of vision yeah
yeah this is dope all right now i'm
gonna go sleep
all right guys you did it koi thank you
turned around my car on my birthday sat
back down in this seat
thanks cosmic wonder all right guys
listen we are huge luke jacobson fans
biggest luke jacobs
dakota north number one
he's in a panel and he looks like fabio
we definitely did not hunt down did not
what that character's last name was very
important research who luke jacobson was
passed
and he's essential to the mcu and
griffin matthews played him perfect
to what i recall of all the comics of
earth 616. look at him look at him guys
essential he looks like uh fabio he got
hit by the face of the goose
but they woke it up
they made him a person of color why
would they ruin my luke jake
the fandom will be upset for weeks this
is [ __ ] guys never gonna be the same
because one page on wiki says iris is
blue not true anymore
marvel doesn't care about the fans or
the source material what can i never see
an iris listing but now it's betrayal
all right koi take it away talk talk it
up this i think was a great use of what
25 minutes of tv can be i think it was
really smart to use all the back
characters to kind of retroactively give
them more importance i really didn't
expect them to come back and be used as
there's a moment when they show the
she-hulk logo being used by um tatiana
maslany's character nope sorry titania
their names being so similar uh by
titania and it doesn't have a hyphen and
i thought there'd be like some
conjecture there but instead i thought
it was really clever to use the seeds
planted earlier now that being said i am
slightly vexed that we don't get more
courtroom things i feel like they give
us all this setup for a courtroom and
then the courtroom itself is like three
minutes so i'm enjoying the show i think
it's really funny i'm enjoying the humor
i think it's really well written but i'm
hoping that once we get daredevil we get
more of a matt murdock and the court
daredevil in the bedroom i hope we get
like a little bit more of the the
dedication for three episodes to some
courtroom stuff little little devil in
the sheets lawyer in the streets
that's gonna be on my business card
if i ever get one printed up
i would like to see that
and what string of circumstances can
necessitate an episode where it's just
either in the bedroom or in the
courtroom
she takes on involves her bringing in
one of her passions
in bed that's a testify the the
courtroom scenes feel like an
educational program for
the youth to understand law
how do you do fellowships
they're so like
they're so basic and so short and
they're written like short films and
it's so frustrating because the show is
so that's what i was saying with like
all the the easter eggs and seed
planning it's written well the show's
written to deliver on things you don't
realize they're setting up i wouldn't
have thought that the setup from the
dates would lead to her winning the
court case that's clever but then once
you're in the courtroom it's like we
don't want audiences to get bored like
they skip over trusting us i want them
to trust us to let us have some lawyer
aaron sorkin has been a whole career out
of courtroom stuff yeah and it's well
written like i just i want the show to
trust us i wanna i want some more
courtrooms there's a lack of
zest
juice
you gotta put some juice
you gotta make the lemonade
that's the thing is that the courtroom
bits are always like a side dish and i'm
always like this is a perfectly pleasant
side dish i like it could i have this as
an entree i taste this yeah could you
season this up and make it a full
portion because it's like they're not
bad scenes but i am
with you in that i would wish they would
dig into the nitty-gritty of some of the
actual like ideas behind just
superheroes existing in society at all
and maybe again you don't have to do
good luck we don't all have to be aiming
to pass a legal eagle reaction breakdown
or something like that but yeah like dig
into the actual law enough so that
somebody in college who's going to law
school can be like oh i actually did
learn a little bit about that because i
was never bored in the daredevil netflix
show when they were in the courtroom i
always wanted more of that yeah are we
weird do we just need courtroom drama
it's called attorney in law first right
now yeah yeah
i just it feels a little bit perfunctory
and like there's a lack of i mean we can
use performance correctly give them a
courtroom scene we talk
um yeah i mean i we talked so much much
about it last episode so we don't have
to like we you guys know how we feel i
actually i think i didn't find the
episode really fun though i want more
pug and nicki adventures i really love
that pug has this ability
to say dialogue that shouldn't be fun
like he'll add a little like spice to
the middle of a word and then nikki her
chaos energy is just like she opens a
scene with this incredible puckishness
yeah i love her mercutio energy i was
familiar with the actor who plays pug
for playing adrian chase on the arrow
show
so it's like adrian chase is from
entredaughter
and chase
adrian
episode is it really wait what's his
name oh it's very chase what is it
adrian grenier
no no chase
adrian from uh no from from uh who's
who's the character in peacemaker
johnson vigilante vigilante that actor
and what's the real what's what's his
actual name
it's adrian something isn't it is it
isn't it yeah isn't it adrian i thought
it was your chase yeah it is you guys
are laughing at me wait no that guy's
character name is that actor's real name
is adrian no we're getting way lost here
that character was also an arrow okay a
more accurate depiction of him but his
oh vigilante vigilantes
this is a dream chase but vinnie chase
from entourage real name is adrian
grenier so i thought you were combining
adrian grignard and then he chased guys
starring billy what a long time
absolutely foreign
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
uh so yeah he i was remembering his
portrayal there yeah
so he played hatred and chase right now
i'm questioning yeah
he's the first person who comes up if
you google it okay okay good good good
good all right good that got it right
i'm familiar with in there which was a
more serious like charismatic but more
serious obviously because they went for
the gravitas on arrow and so to see him
here and really loosen that is quite a
journey
i feel i i i do find it like um it's
exciting to me to see so i like when i'm
so used to seeing an actor do serious
work to now do something that's just
solely playful because it could have
been
it is a portrayal that could easily be
um like i don't quite get what they're
going for with this guy because he's
supposed to his last step there was one
episode where he was like a really damn
good lawyer right but there was another
episode where he was like this is a
great poop
so he could do both though he found that
he found the tone where he can hop in
and out of being childlike but then also
being a really good lawyer
lawyer in the streets yeah man he's
nailing it yeah and uh what do you think
about the costume guy john i really
enjoyed our boy luke jacobson
matthews killing it or michael whatever
his last name is no no i mean i thought
that was a really fun sequence i mean
obviously it's designed to make you go
where's the easter eggs in the room but
uh we didn't find many i'll tell you
that much guardian suit uh obviously we
got excited
as you saw a few minutes ago just
freaking out uh i didn't really know
what to make of the blue mask or the um
deep background uh mannequin that had
like gold but that might have just been
them spraying gold to like make the
daredevil suit yeah yeah could be but i
thought that was really fun and i
thought that was yeah like as a means of
getting her to the actual costume but
also as a means of upgrading that really
frumpy suit she has been that whole
thing about looking like a college that
was really college
football player trying to plead no
contest to something or other i was like
yeah that is exactly what now i will say
and i've already gotten in trouble for
seeing things ahead of time and kicked
out of episode three but while we're
here i did to get to see footage of d23
of matt murdock and she hulk and i won't
describe the actual footage but i will
say i was impressed with the balance of
comedy and drama because we've seen
charlie cox play a netflix very gritty
daredevil and that character would feel
like a sore thumb in this show what
they're able to do is really impressive
and that he's very much still daredevil
and he's very much how charlie cox plays
him but the dialogue is so so snappy and
the interaction between the two of them
makes it feel like a team up comic where
you've got almo it almost felt like and
this is very comicky it almost felt like
two different artists doing a jam piece
together on a panel in the middle of a
comic book so it felt like it meshed but
you could feel the different line work
from two different artists on one page
and it was so much fun did daredevil
walk into a door
he did not
zero pratfalls
i promise you that's safe
but he looked awesome in his yellow suit
he tried shaking jennifer walter's hand
and then accidentally touched her boob
now he he waved like stevie wonder was
that way but stevie wonder at that thing
oh my god
did they go to court to negotiate the
rights back from netflix we did not see
we saw the scene of daredevil but we
also saw in that preview you guys
reviewed uh we do have matt murdock in
the show that
did he uh do a whole speech to the jury
but he was facing the wrong direction he
did
you're not even in the courtroom matt
come on outside stop that's the only
machine and they were like okay that's
enough courtroom stuff get out of here
we don't want this to get boring funny
for our non-law students
no but i i was really impressed at the
balancing of tones and it's a really
sweet scene and it was only like three
minutes but i'm i'm so excited for that
to come i assume that's next week and
i'm thinking now because of the amount
of setup i think we get matt for at
least two episodes maybe the last three
because that felt substantial like that
felt like we were gonna get something
real i mean yeah they teased it for a
reason and the trailers have been really
teasing a lot lately too and it's like
the show's doing bad it's got great
viewership i like mallory quite a bit
yeah
they they butt heads a lot i mean she
doesn't like she-hulk in the comics
right and it takes it's a while before
they actually start working together but
i like how they're starting it off on a
on a playing field where they're not
quite friends yeah i like this
insecurity that jennifer has where she
needs to be liked
there's a really fun thing in the comics
right now where mallory's actually
jennifer's boss and it's the opposite of
the show where they have a law firm
where she's like you can do anything but
you're forbidden from doing superhero
law and so like she keeps getting all
these clients that are her friends that
are like but we need you and she's like
that's the one thing i can't do so it's
really fun reading the current shield
comics on issue six right now i would
recommend it uh and then having that
like dichotomy and then mallory this
most recent issue spoilers rip issue six
it's miles spoiler uh she decides to rep
the x-men and then she gets the entire
island of krakowa and mallory is like
all right fine that's a high-paying
client those are great like blah blah
blah so it's really fun to see the
characterization on the show versus how
it's reading in the comics with the
exact opposite objective how do you feel
about the mallory portrayal here i think
it's great because it's still uh
endearing like the thing about stuck-up
characters is they're immediately
written off if they don't have humanity
in them and malaria
especially especially when you're like
she's a [ __ ]
i'll be happy if she dies yeah get rid
of her but like this character on paper
can read very stiff and very uh you know
one note so what i really like about
mallory in the show in the comic is that
there's a couple glances that endear you
to her there's a couple moments of like
you see the empathy wash over her face
whether she wants to verbalize it or not
like you felt that she felt for jennifer
walters even though she hates her like
and not even hates but like she just
doesn't like dealing with her
so i i really enjoy that mallory is able
to give us silent cues as an audience to
what she's going through and again i
really enjoy the the what this
perspective of what female uh
protagonists and heroes go through i
really like the you know not being able
to walk in home night with headphones
because
this is a very selfish example but i
love walking the streets of hollywood
with headphones on and i like usually
make tick tocks of like this is where i
am that's what i'm listening to and
everybody's like you're going to die and
i don't think about it and one day it
might happen but i don't think about it
i'm not a woman like i just go out
walking and like i like that the show
addresses that isn't something that
everyone gets to do like the world sucks
for a lot of people it's funny when she
said that i was like i would so hate to
not be able to do that because i love
joy
and then in that moment and it's not
like i've never felt it before but yeah
in that moment you feel the pain of like
damn a lot of people really can't do
that yeah i thought about it like in
very literal sense yeah wow that one
line really struck a chord with you that
was the main takeaway from this episode
i don't care about you
as a cis white man i need to re-examine
my whole white life right now
do i have
privilege
such a fast lives
i'm having an existential crisis right
now everything in my life
will not walk the streets i took that
away from this episode as well as the
phrase one to stock one to rock
or vice versa whatever
yeah that's a good line yeah because
they i mean everybody's got something
where they're like yeah i gotta get one
to keep nice i love that character so
much like i don't know what it is about
pug but i feel like he's my daryl like i
really like the daryl stuff with thor
but it didn't hit me quite as much as it
did pop culture but pug is my exact
humor like every time vlog's here i'm
like my boy wait a minute if if uh
what's his name lauren jacobs
jake jacobs jacob uh if luke jacobson's
in the show does that mean melvin is not
gonna be in him because melvin's great
melvin potter melvin was so personal and
perfect for daredevil and and like that
the grittiness you've already got a soup
from it i like that he was an
anti-villain like he wasn't a hero he
was like a guy that just was ta he was
like sandman he was tough on his luck
and just trying to get through and he
was doing something you know to to
redeem himself yeah i don't know how
much we're going to get from the disney
place
it's just
yeah who reached out to luke on behalf
of matt like how's that meeting going
and two i couldn't help but think at the
end i was like is that helmet finished
cause it's all scuffed up
it's not painted fully
should finish that there it looks like
it just got here is that like chic so
that's gonna be who he go who's i mean
it looks like luke jacobson's the
character for all the street level like
when all the defenders come back
that's the new melvin i think that's
that's who punisher is going to go to to
get the skull done
[Laughter]
anymore
that scene that everybody memes like no
no that's him like in the swing shot
that's him when he sees the dazzle chest
piece he's still like looking around
like
just say thank you frank just say thank
you
they do the whole welcome back frank arc
but it's him in that shop just fairly
upset having ptsd about his kids
how do you guys feel about the vfx
did rush this episode i noticed it more
than others actually which is funny
because i know a lot of people had
issues with three but this one that was
moments where her face was super
detailed especially in the scene with
todd the dude that came back they kept
cutting to her face and i was like whoa
they like really honed in but then other
scenes when she's like walking through
the courtroom i was like yeah there was
there was a couple like the wait issue
there was a like a wait like well i
noticed one and maybe it's only because
we have headphones on
the there's something that i felt that
could have been a decent fix for how
because usually sound design is so
subtle and how effective it is like you
you a lot of times you might not notice
sound design unless something's off with
the sound sure um and i noticed that
when she's talking it sounds like she's
in a recording booth versus the other
people there's a bit of a muffle
to her where it doesn't sound like she's
in the same room
like if you watch her first scene where
she's with mallory
it it does not sound especially
distracting when you got oh my god blake
who's the other girl's name not mallory
uh titania the villain no nikki when
like nikki mallory and she-hulk are all
in the same room two sound like they're
in the room yeah and then one sounds
like a a weird audio recording
like adr almost it makes me wonder how
they shoot those in terms of the
performance because there is a credited
actress who is the she-hulk eye line
reference
yeah so i i
would i wonder if they have tatiana
maslany pipe in
the dialogue and then record it later or
if she's even there well you gotta have
two days you gotta have good sound
mixing for a situation like that because
it it pulls me out because it does it
sounds it it makes me aware that she's
not in the room with them yeah and i
don't know how that i don't know if that
like it happens with you guys when
you're watching it but for me i started
feeling it it's like it plays on me on a
subconscious level
like now you have an audio version of
the video like of that issue so that
that is distracting i didn't notice it
but i could definitely see where that
would be now you will it frowns
it fractures the movie magic a little
bit i mean for me the effects have kind
of sunk have kind of leveled out into a
place where i'm like yeah some of the
shots are really good some of the shots
i have a bunch of reasons in my head as
to why they don't look as good as those
other shots
i like the character enough that i don't
really care that's kind of where i'm at
like i notice it when you ask and when i
replay it my head but like i'm not in
the show being like oof like i'm just
like all right this is what we have the
show's moving too fast for me to like
be [ __ ] yeah it's already going
like so quick and there's so much like
like a lot of it feels like they had to
like we gotta pair this down we gotta
put this down 28 minutes there are times
where it does feel like that that sick
call me like we gotta we gotta ship chip
this up come on come on yeah so um
and for the kind of show it is it
doesn't bother me uh in that regard like
i'm not here going i wish you the only
thing i really wish was better was the
courtroom seat i find the courtroom
scenes just lack some type of
some type of stakes or drama it does bug
me a lot because it just feels so like
we do like we just have to do it because
we have to do it but it's like the comic
has lawyers there's no excitement for or
passion for the writing behind it i'm
really hoping that that's kind of a
bothering point i mean
yeah it would be nice to get it that'd
be great at least for the daredevil show
which has 18 episodes
19 of them are going to be dedicated to
matt at least
just doing his opening statement
[Music]
written by mike flanagan that's how they
saved in the budget i gotta give props
too to jamila jamil cause i find it
funny at least the things i'm familiar
with seeing her and she has a corn she's
cornered this sort of
spectrum of of
i don't know cringe vaguely public
figures and i've
forgot whilst watching this like oh
that's right she's british
and uh and she sinks into that like
insipid influencer so quickly so well i
had legit ptsd looking at that set i was
like i've been in these rooms with these
people and it is those are awful they're
they're awful yeah and it's like it's
not
we're the most anti-influencers it's not
honey from the good place but it's like
on a certain part of the spectrum from
from her like adjacent where it's like
that character like is a do-gooder but
in an obnoxious lurid way and this
character is not but in just as
obnoxious and just as lurid of a way and
jamil jamil is such a like wholesome
like giving kind compassionate charity
person like chamilla gmail is so she's
so like down to earth and like let me
help you and then she plays these vapid
preposterous it's like it's really
impressive i like i like her i think she
does a really good job i do wish the
writing of the sh sometimes i feel like
you gotta sort of acknowledge some of
the ridiculousness of the situation
well i was like she she just attacked a
court full of people three days ago
yeah it was not long ago like what's she
what's the discussion that's being had
here right now like how come no one's
even
saying that like your honor this woman
just attacked everyone and because they
explained it away in a crawl that most
people didn't see two episodes ago which
was what there was some crawl at the
bottom of one of the news screens it's
like oh titania's lawyers you know blah
blah blah about courtroom like they
they've i believe
you can go back and fact check me but
it's in one of those bottom crawls it's
like they expect to have all the charges
dropped or whatever why
i don't know why isn't that why is that
not a discussion she literally
broke put a kool-aid man wall
background of infinity war because the
show's over and it's really hard to know
that like these things with this much
weight lives in the same world and i
don't need everything to be the same
tone i like that the mcu is disparate
tones but i do want occasional moments
of gravity to ground us back in like i
just need the occasional moment of like
have levity have this humor but i just
like you know i need to land again so
that when we connect to the next show it
feels like it is one universe the one
the one thing that i am liking is
part of the um
part of the thing that like emotionally
makes me cringe in a good way because i
i care for jennifer walters very much
let me try to make sure i communicate
this right because i want this to come
across the wrong way um because i want
to sound like a negative is what i'm
saying is that like when she's talking
with nikki on the bench and she's like i
went on a date she-hulk went on a date
like that complete
this disassociation i am not her
like that part of me always makes me
like kind of like
tighten up on the inside for her the
character because it's like it's his
struggle for acceptance of herself and
then you know you see how she is with
mallory at the end like i'm so glad
we're friends and she's embarrassed by
saying that because clearly she wanted
to be liked she's so much more confident
in she-hulk i love that about her yeah
and so and and then you know you also
see that in the courtroom scene when the
one guy who she did sleep with is like
not much that jennifer walter's on my
type but she-hulk she's amazing and
she's smiling about it and i was like no
no you you are both you accept it and i
think that's going to be the end of the
season is her accepting she is she-hulk
because she'll ever i am iron man moment
but i want a little bit more of the
pathos there you know i'd love to see
that spelled out and like maybe we'll
get that in a movie like maybe maybe the
you know with the fleshed-out cgi and
like you know the inevitable you know
west coast avengers or what have you i'd
love to see that played around with
that'd be nice but i do struggle with
like how much i'm invested in both and
feeling like they have to rush to the
other one yeah that's a good point i
thought there were nice little moments
just acknowledging to that point about
the the line between jen and she hulk
and the way in which that can create
sort of a
i don't know just like a negative
self-view or a negative just
disassociation from self i thought there
were interesting instances like is when
she runs into the guy from miracle
workers in the lobby
that first date and she's like kind of
even though that was a crappy date she's
still kind of like
you know eager to please and and kind of
trying to be genial and i feel like
there were little flourishes like that
especially with the guys coming back
through that felt kind of natural in
that sort of like oh yeah if you really
search your soul and think about you
know valuing yourself you probably
wouldn't be so genial towards these
people who don't really seem to actually
care for and respect you but in social
situations you can find yourself
inclined to be more genial i thought
that was kind of a lived in detail
i don't recall her being this
self-conscious
in the comics no no in the in the show
like i feel like she'd be more
comfortable standing up for herself i
feel like she wasn't uh always but like
with bruce she was which i thought was
an interesting like family dynamic like
she was very confident with bruce but
when we got her back to the world
remember with the all the girls in the
bathroom she was like no no like she
didn't want help like i always feel like
she's she's wavering like she's got she
seemed like extra self-conscious this
episode maybe because of everything
that's happening maybe yeah but i'm
really curious because like i i don't
know if you guys shared this but i i
personally uh struggle with the online
persona versus real life persona and
i've i've been wondering about the
duality of superheroes and like whether
or not i feel like that's a disparate
person like when you meet people in real
life they're used to your online persona
and i'm really interested in how
she-hulk like accepting her she-hulk
versus how she walks around as jim
walters and those things feel like
there's a lot of venn diagram but
there's separateness and now looking at
the world like a lot of us spend more of
our time online than in person so are we
if we spend more time as at ourselves
versus who we ourselves are is that the
more real person so if you spend more
time as she hulk are you less jennifer
walters if i spend more time on twitter
am i less the person i am off twitter
join me in like that that duality of how
you represent you i think you're asking
deeper questions in this show might
actually you know what i just
don't like if you're asking i think
they're gonna ask you you're interested
in the exploration of that
you want to explore the thing they want
to touch up my name
courtroom drama
all right we'll be over there i think
they'll they'll say that like briefly
yeah but i don't feel like it's like
it's a fascinating concept that i and i
feel like i feel like tatiana mislani's
doing it though i feel like oh yeah
anyway that's what i'm saying i read
more into what she's doing more than i
feel like there's a lot of conversations
with the director and her yeah i agree
on how to capture this character
but yeah all right guys
what'd you think about this episode i
mean overall i enjoyed it i had fun it's
fun i liked it uh it's back to like
issue issue episode one and two for me
three and four a little bit fell off for
me this this reminded me of like where i
was in the stride i didn't love the
demon fight yeah i didn't love all the i
liked it more than episode four yeah a
lot of people were like walkers and all
that and it was fun but like this is
this is my dream i really disagree with
this one episode yeah oh yeah i know
people are like madison and i mean i
like i like madison
yeah i'm more a pug nicky ship than a
wonger's madison ship yeah yeah people
were all about that yeah
i liked it they got their own twitter
hashtags with emotes on it yeah
and so does madison
she's got two two hands
daredevil's gonna save everything guys
we got excited you saw it
three grown men one in the morning
yelling about a yellow suit they could
have daredevil go to sit down on the
toilet and miss and i'm gonna be like
he's back baby
where's that echo location now matt make
the blind jokes yep they're coming is
that ableist and then there'll be a
bunch of blind people upset at the show
and us we just made a [ __ ] poop joke
it's okay they're not watching
they might be listening
[Laughter]
you don't know i was gonna say you don't
know that they have uh
maybe youtube will get those captions
that also describe things to you are we
in braille out loud yeah all right
oh my god that'd be so cool
everyone's the three guys the three guys
the three guys are losing their [ __ ]
over a yellow helmet over a yellow
helmet in a box
in the future
all right
happy birthday
guys
your birthday here i'm happy to be here
there's a great way to kick off this
year and um
john yeah they're expecting i'm here
i'm always i'm always here
john got my favorite drink that can't be
named and greg got me my favorite drink
to camping ape because we want to make
sure that youtube doesn't hate us but
they're really good
water
jeter
looked up your name on urban dictionary
yes it's a good one gene it's a good one
a tall sexy beast with a firm ass and
very broad shoulders great ass it looks
so good from behind that you'd agree to
go on a date with him without having
seen his face that ass getting all kinds
of latest numbers
these days check this out he picks you
up
for lunch
he is confident chatty and intelligent
that is very accurate
he makes you laugh and he eats like a
horse
even from other people's plates but it's
not rude when he does it no no because
he makes hoarse noises the whole time
it's a damn superpower because he is so
tall and thin guy can consume like a
garbage dumpster and never gains weight
stupid that is a gift
as time goes on it's revealed that he's
not just brilliant at math science and
business i'll throw in spelling he can
also fix anything the dude is like a
mechanic for the world how is he real no
one knows he handles his money well
and is a master in the sheets and
cleaning sheets you want to stop time
and exist forever in his red bedroom
eyes wide gene constant pleasure from
just a look
woman couldn't exist on snacks sleeping
with him
his dna should be bottled and sold i
have some so we can produce more gene
jeters his offsprings are tall
tan and striking
gene factory they are all if you thought
gene was great wait till you see the
children
his attributes do not fade with age he
gets better the older he gets if you
find one you'll want to keep him and we
sure have
gene
you're sticking around and the odds of
you being the one who wrote this
are high very high and likely you're
named after your own good genes by the
sound of this and if you didn't write
this it's completely accurate so no harm
no find who did and marry them let's
say goodbye on that note but stick
around for next month
[Music]